[Music]
hey before we get into this highlight
clip we just want to let you know we're
doing a live show from the ship
july 29 moment house dot com slash tiny
meat gang
tell them what we're doing we're doing
it's gonna be so much fun we got dj's
head from spock
we got a live that's cringe we're doing
a new cody noel do we're premiering it
no one's ever seen it we learned how to
sword fight it's [ __ ] insane yep and
we got some sketches that we made too
and two hours or more of us just riffing
and yeah
might have some special guests drop by
all around good time
so yeah come join us it's going to be
it's going to be awesome and
you know just so you all know once the
show happens it'll be available for
24 hours after the show happens so in
case you bought a ticket but you miss it
you can still watch it for the day after
but after that
it's finito is gone so uh make sure you
tune in
july 29th it's gonna be a good time
momenthouse.comgang
anyways uh new maine vs blue face
new face versus blue main so what do we
got what is the story here so
what the f why like they're and they're
not only fighting they're
not their knuckles bare knuckles holy
[ __ ]
yeah it's a bare knuckle event
dude this is gonna be atrocious for new
maine
blueface used to be an athlete like a
straight-up athlete what did he play
football
really yeah jesus he went to college for
and said this isn't for me
left i mean this is going to be lamar
odom versus aaron carter yeah way
worse because it's 100 knuckle boxing
with no headgear right is that what it
is
um i would assume no headgear and uh i
mean this [ __ ] is getting more and more
intense it went from
ksi versus logan paul you know amateur
fight gear
gloves to reel boxing pro fight
to bare knuckle bare knuckle bc
fc next is just going to be dudes
youtubers head running each other
yeah head butting competition head body
competition cte
this the the cte uh world challenge
uh it's [ __ ] mr beast first mark
whatever engineer guy
oh mark robert mark robert versus mr
beast
[Laughter]
head slamming competition yeah bruh
against the wall
but yeah looking yeah
straight up dual pistols
yeah play that i wonder if it's bkfc
putting this on
blueface's reach is crazy
i just don't i don't really i don't get
it
i mean just what's the point
he needs the attention i guess but the
dude is an actor
you know he learned that from the whole
first ordeal he considers himself an
actor
maybe this is just promo for
his boxing movie oh is bare knuckle
boxing
yeah no just that's just rocky word for
word
or or or no
maybe he is applying his acting
techniques
to boxing where he's just like you know
he watches and other boxers fight
and he goes i take your [ __ ] and i make
it better i
get better so he's gonna practice
another fighter's routine and just make
it better
i'm gonna get knocked out like you but
i'm gonna do it better let's get knocked
out with a smile
[Laughter]
no he's gonna get knocked out and then
stand up and be like
that's acting that's acting baby you
think he'd get knocked out and then just
try to sell it like i was paid to take a
dive
i at this point anything's possible any
[ __ ] thing is possible
who do you think the ceo of this company
is
let's find out ceo sorry i kind of had a
little struggle
who do you think who do you think is the
pair of knuckles in charge
that's the that's the title they use at
that promotion what pair of knuckles in
charge
yeah yeah yeah is that the
name of the company okay knuckles pair
of knuckles in charge pair of knuckles
blue face social knuckles
we see austin new broom lurking in the
background no no no wait no one's
getting paid
next up on instagram knuckles
that's what it's called yo i just
thought about
the this births like a new age karen
where they start going up to boxing
events
asking to see if they have like nevada
state commission papers to like run the
event
yeah there's an illegal boxing match
occurring here
[Laughter]
hold up blue face new main
uh bare knuckle
it just keeps auto completing the
bareback i want bare knuckle
bare knuckle dude blue face y'all click
that
oh this is great
oh it's bkfc no way dude
do you see that yeah what is bkfc so
paige vanson she was one of the hosts
or one of the commentators for the
tiktok fight yeah
uh she's the headliner for this one
she's bare knuckle boxing
yeah this is like her second bare
knuckle fight
paige doesn't play man she fights likes
to fight for real
is this like way bloodier oh yeah it's
pretty brutal really
yeah is it like not even fun to watch
it's pretty rough i've watched it it's
just it's kind of tough
it's like watching street fights yeah
it's always a little bit like yeah yeah
until somebody
you hear that sound well it's full on
you're like oh
the thing with the street fight is
people miss shots these are like
guys that have done this their whole
life yeah so those fists hit
yeah so a jab it's like a bare knuckle
jab
yeah that's it just yep and if they land
a hook
that goes flush on the cheeks everything
you know
yeah which you know mma is pretty close
[Laughter]
i'm a new man all these boxing accounts
show up on my instagram discover so
there's a clip of blue face and
immediately i went to the comments and
the caption was blue face working out
uh for his it was like similar to this
working out for his boxing match and the
top comment was he's gonna need to work
on a whole lot
i was like again online bullying man
not one single comment of encouragement
it's just
l he looks like the fighting irish logo
it's that one uh nah play that training
video again
he's got to be joking man go to the
fighting just search fighting irish
he can't actually fight like that
they said this
[Laughter]
hey come on come on
i'm just saying blueface has
some degree of experience performing as
an athlete
so that matters new mane
newman's gonna get the michael lee
treatment times five
i don't even know how he could possibly
think there's any chance that he's gonna
win that
there's no benefit to this it's nothing
like he just only gets his ass kicked
i mean why would you do that this kid is
a he's just a walking
l yeah see what
see how it's it's rubbing off on me yeah
you see how mean it is
it is i mean that was the meanest thing
you could say out of anything he
deserves it
no no i'm just saying like you could say
yeah he stole content but if you're like
fools like l ow yeah ouch yeah
so much meaner yeah it really is he's
like mid as a person
that one really is the worst song he's
mid
mid or l yeah it's all the comments in
this bonus episode are going to be like
mid
episode yb had a better episode
yeah you know the worst is when
oh ratio we forgot ratio oh yeah right
ratio that one actually is the worst
yeah no you know what's gonna happen is
someone's gonna comment l on this and
it's gonna get a ton of like likes and
then
there'll be a chain beneath it they're
like dub l dub dub
which is even ruder yeah but oh saying
dub to the l yeah
uh damn two layers man
inception that's wild yeah [ __ ]
yeah newman and it's here's the thing
with new maine he's not like a jake paul
where i want to see him get
[ __ ] up no you think i mean yeah he is
kind of a dick
but he hasn't like he hasn't pissed
people off that much there was that one
time and i guess
has he has he kept stealing content he
has
so he's still doing it okay well then
yeah yeah
get his punch get his punch face then
let's get his face punched
here's the thing i i'd be just you know
a little bit more okay with it with
gloves
so you get your ass kicked with gloves
you know everyone gets what they want he
gets punched in the face he looks like a
doofus
cause after what happened with bryce it
doesn't take much to make you look like
an [ __ ] in the room right
yeah but bare knuckle like that kid's
gonna die in there yeah
like everyone will get what they want
and more
you see like it's like his face is gonna
be cut open
look up he's gonna die l he's gonna die
in there he'll he's gonna be the death
that people
exactly that's what we should have said
in the last episode kind of mid
death honestly
that's so [ __ ] sorry [ __ ] up uh
look up artem lobov
r-a-r-t-e-m-l-o-b-o-v
bare knuckle
and then just go to images gore warning
look at that one
like he looks like that was from bare
knuckles yeah he looks that's like a
halloween mask bro
did you see who maleed was fighting
my little dick in your mouth nice try
brother
nice try was good look at that [ __ ] on
the left dude
oh jesus he looks like a michael myers
victim bro
okay no more fighting yeah no more no no
more no more no
enough no more fighting because it's
time to talk about my go-kart and i'm
just getting scared just kidding